[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture au
sommaire aujourd'hui la compagnie en
flux en scène en résidence au théâtre
l'espace coluche à plaisir l'occasion
pour les comédiens de mettre en scène
leur nouveau spectacle viennent 1913 une
expérience qui leur permet d'aller à la
rencontre des spectateurs
un court métrage made in yvelines
charmer pas ces charmants fait écho à
l'épidémie présentée lors du festival
des courts métrages sur smartphone
organisé par l'association le cinoche
le film a obtenu le prix coup de coeur
du public le château de versailles ouvre
exceptionnellement la galerie des
sculptures et des moulages au programme
sculptures originales à des jardins de
versailles ou encore moulage du musée du
louvre
d'après l'antique plus d'un millier
d'oeuvres sont à découvrir
je vous le disais en titre la compagnie
influence n est en résidence au théâtre
espace coluche à plaisir l'occasion pour
les comédiens de mettre en scène leur
nouveau spectacle deviennent 1913 la
compagnie sera présentée jusqu'au 20
novembre date des représentations
patrick jacques de dixmude s'est rendu
répétition on reviendra demain
enfin un beau dessin pour que je fasse
une belle vie elle n'oublie pas de
signer c'est quoi ta signature à bob
doll bonne nuit la donne une résidence
de trois mois pour créer mettre en scène
le spectacle viennent 1913 elle permet à
la compagnie influence n2 bénéficier de
l'équipement du théâtre pour répéter
avec le décor donc ils peuvent améliorer
le décor le construire éventuellement
ils peuvent faire la création des
lumières dont ils ont toute une équipe
de régisseur à leur disposition on nous
devons nous tue
la plateau un accès au plateau ça c'est
tout à fait essentiel pour pouvoir créer
et on me donne la possibilité aussi de
rencontrer public rencontré le public
grâce à des répétitions ouvertes aux
spectateurs mais aussi à d'autres
actions comme la réalisation dès samedi
des inédits permettant de présenter
d'autres spectacles un partenariat sur
toute une saison
il ya beaucoup d'autres actions qui vont
avoir lieu dont les samedis des inédits
qui sont aussi initiés par la compagnie
influencent elles qui vont permettre
aussi au public de découvrir des textes
inédits d'auteurs vivants
c'est vraiment une évolution tout au
long de la saison où les gens vont
finalement rencontrer les artistes sous
des angles différents
pendant la résidence des rencontres sont
organisées avec les lycées collèges ou
encore associations
objectif proposer au public des
tracteurs de cette création
il ya des retours il ya des questions
qu'ont fait un petit bout de répète
comme ça dans la salle du lycée non mais
ça on leur montre un petit bout comme ça
de travail ils nous posent des questions
et le fait qu'ils nous posent des
questions sur ce qu'ils viennent de voir
ça nous ça me fait réfléchir on ça nous
permet de creuser d'alimenter encore
plus notre travail
deux représentations auront lieu le 20
novembre à 14h30 et à 18h45 au théâtre
espace coluche un court métrage made in
yvelines charmer pas ces charmants été
réalisée dans le cadre d'ateliers
organisés par l'association le cinoche
la vidéo d'une vingtaine de minutes a
été tourné en quatre jours seulement le
film était présenté lors du festival de
courts métrages sur smartphone à magny
les hameaux
il a obtenu le prix coup de coeur du
public regardez charmer pas si charmant
un court métrage réalisé par une équipe
de six cinéastes en herbe un projet de
20 minutes qui fait écho à l'actualité
on était un groupe avec des jeunes et
des moins jeunes donc voilà ça nous a
permis de mettre en place une bonne
dynamique et c'est un court métrage sur
ce qui se passe avec des méchants virus
qui arrive à un moment donné et ce qui
se passe quand on est une petite
collectivité tête de radio
le projet résulte d'un atelier organisé
sur plusieurs jours par l'association le
cinoche il permettait d'apprendre les
techniques du cinéma sur smartphone
c'est un atelier sur ces quatre jours
continue donc tous les jours on est venu
pour travailler avec thomas et enzo qui
nous ont bien coachés et puis mes
camarades de tournage grâce à cette
expérience les comédiens amateurs ont pu
découvrir l'envers du décor hélène nous
raconte une anecdote de tournage
tout d'un coup on s'est mis entendre un
marteau piqueur juste à côté
et c'était la boucherie à côté qui
venait refaire entièrement le magasin
donc là on a eu un peu peur et puis on a
quand même pu arriver à travailler avec
eux quand travaillez pas en faisait nos
tournage donc voila un petit peu les
aléas des fois de du cinéma l'équipe a
présenté son film au festival de courts
métrages sur smartphone organisé par le
cinoche à magny les hameaux charmer pas
ces charmants a reçu le prix coup de
coeur du public
le château de versailles ouvre
exceptionnellement la galerie des
sculptures et des moules à jusqu'à la
fin de l'année l'occasion de contempler
des sculptures originales des jardins de
versailles sous louis xiv
plus d'un millier d'oeuvres sont à
découvrir astrid berges est allé à la
rencontre des visiteurs les chevaux du
soleil ou encore le vase de la paix
voilà ce que vous pouvez découvrir à
versailles
la galerie des sculptures et des
moulages ouvre exceptionnellement ses
portes au public jusqu'au 27 décembre
une installation accueillis dans la
petite écurie du roi sur place plus d'un
millier d'oeuvres de quoi marquer les
visiteurs le cas là quand le avec
cendres s'est pas il fait au moins 5
mètres de haut
cet apollon c'est alexandre c'est
vraiment aussi y paraît et alexandre qui
fait cinq minutes j'ai dit mais comment
ils ont amené vraiment c'est magnifique
l'occasion de voir des moulages du musée
du louvre d'après l'antique ou encore
des sculptures originales des jardins du
célèbre château les trois quarts ont été
copiés au cours du temps puisqu'elle se
sont abîmés
finalement avec des intempéries en
particulier et puis c'est l'occasion de
les voir grandeur nature et puis elles
s'offrent à nous finalement avec le
grain du marbre original qu'elles ont
l'installation a attiré amateurs et
passionnés
pour certains elle était l'occasion de
mieux percevoir louis xiv mais aussi de
visualiser l'art de vivre à l'époque
baroque le canon de beauté en fait
surtout féminins et masculins qu'on
voyait à l'époque de louis xiv fut que
on reprend l'art antique et on reprend
la mythologie vu que louis xiv en plus
se démarque en apollon dieu du soleil
des arts et de la danse
la galerie des sculptures et des
moulages sera ouverte au public tous les
week ends jusqu'au 27 décembre a depuis
les dernières mesures gouvernementales
le monde culturel tentent de s'adapter
malgré ce à plusieurs événements doivent
être annulées ou reportées
c'est le cas notamment pour le 4e salon
du livre d'elancourt dans les yvelines
il devait prendre place à la commanderie
sur le thème de tintin au grand reporter
du 21e siècle
initialement prévue le 29 novembre il
est reporté au 23 mai 2021 en raison de
la crise sanitaire
et puis le festival blues sur seine lui
aussi a dû être annulé
la 22e édition à devait se tenir du 6 au
21 novembre le rendez vous est donc
donné en 2021 cependant cinq
représentations sont maintenus pendant
le mois de novembre
comme jean jacques milteau aux blues
buteur pote nathalie et de ses chante
nougaro ou encore eric macé taux plus
d'informations sur le site internet
blues sur seine points comme le mois
manga est de retour pour une quatrième
édition à saint cyr l'école
au programme de nouvelles de nombreuses
animations à des ateliers et un concours
pour en parler sur ce plateau justement
à celje agathe saint gobain soir avant
soir alors expliquez nous pourquoi les
saint cyriens organise
souvent manga alors c'est une initiative
lancée il ya quatre ans sous l'impulsion
du lycée professionnel jean perrin à
saint cyr l'école
les lycéens ont souhaité organiser un
simple concours d'affichés manga en
partenariat avec la bibliothèque albert
camus et la ville est finalement s'en
est suivi un véritable événement dans
toute la commune pauthe clair le manga
est votre combat
bon dans les spas de la littérature et
de l'art en le culturel et donc on
souhaite diffuser nous en tant que ville
ce message est ce c'est cet engouement
et l'eau lire cet engouement qu'il ya
autour du manga autour de l'anim mais
aussi autour de du développement
artistique de l'illustration ses liens
avant de parler des ateliers ce que
peut-être nous rappeler ce qu'est qu'un
manga alors le manga c'est un ouvrage e
dessinée qui vient du japon vous à
dossier quelques titres qui sont chinois
mais surtout il ya une très grosse
culture autour du manga
il y à des dessinateurs très connu et
très apprécié par le public
vous avez des gros succès comme my hero
academia pour la jeunesse pour les
inconditionnels fullmetal alchemist ou
encore bien sûr le grand akira ses
mangas sont à retrouver dans la manga
tech de la bibliothèque albert camus où
plus de 200 titres sont disponibles
vous parliez d'un concours d'affichés
manga est ce qu'il existe toujours
oui vous l'aurez compris ce concours
d'affichés est inhérent au projet
initial du mois manga il est ouvert à
tous les saint cyriens il ya en réalité
deux concours un concours e pour les
moins de 12 ans et un concours pour les
plus de 12 ans avec chaque année un
thème cette année ce sont des métiers
héroïque qui sont à l'honneur un gros
clin d'oeil pour tous ces métiers qui
ont qui ont été impliqués dans la crise
du coc vie de cette année toutes les
affiches sont à déposer à la
bibliothèque
il y aura une exposition des affiches et
un vote à la bibliothèque par le public
je vous comprendre aussi qu'il y aurait
quatre ateliers wii 2 à la bibliothèque
albert camus et deux autres au cirad au
une structure de la ville qui accueille
en périscolaire les collégiens et
lycéens
les ateliers sont annie
par l'illustratrice et mangaka
gwendoline simon qui propose une
initiation au dessin manga à travers
différentes techniques
attention inscription obligatoire et les
mangas peuvent être aussi animé il aura
en effet une projection de trois films
ailleurs lupin iii et akira au cinéma
les yeux d'elsa à saint-cyr-l'ecole une
projection a quelque peu modifié en
raison du couvre-feu film akira on a dû
déplacer certaines séances et changé ses
horaires puisque le film faisant deux
heures et demie et comme on souhaitait
le proposer vers 19h30 20h il était
impossible de recevoir public donc non
effectivement on a modifié un petit peu
là la liste des projections c'est de ces
films mais bon les spectateurs et les
saint cyriens peuvent la retrouver sur
le site de la ville sur www.sears.ca 18
point fr et ils trouveront toute la
programmation modifiée
à la fin du mois manga à une cérémonie
devait avoir lieu pour récompenser tous
les participants
elle est reportée au printemps en 2021 à
cause de la crise tally terre c'est noté
merci célia pour ces informations on
vous retrouve bien sûr mardi pour une
nouvelle émission avec plaisir je vous
en parlais dans un précédent numéro
l'auteur interprète ce call a sorti un
clip au mois d'août
originaire des yvelines le chanteur
présente une gao
le titre a déjà récolté plus de 50000
vues sur youtube
l'artiste nous présente son kit titre
que la base des différentes langues
j'ai vécu cinq ans on nous passe pas ça
en fait c'est un message à l'invitation
changements à venir découvrir l'afrique
j'aimais beaucoup ce qu'ils faisaient
ibrahim il a commencé dans le rap
ensuite il a évolué sous le nom
d'ulysses brio il est plus de conteurs
slameurs et l'image collée avec le avec
moi tout de suite c'est le réalisateur
canadien on a échangé
sincèrement ça c'est fait je pense en
deux semaines sur les idées global
le studio c'était les frites c'est là
que l'extérieur tel prix ici donc ça
facilite aussi la chose et ensuite en
trombe la tournée en 24 heures on a
comme en cent cinq mille ha à huit
heures du matin on a terminé le soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est emile juste à côté d'une pente
d'un champ domicile fixe et qui pendant
tout le tournage a fait qu'on bercy on
était au milieu il ya beaucoup de vélo
qui passe au pied de couper pas mal de
fois en rouge elle est cette personne là
elle sortit de sa tante et a fait en
fait l'orientation des cyclistes et
leurs visas non stop tournage à la
droite à la gauche
nous aider pendant tout le tournage très
touchant on reste dans la musique avec
debout sur le zinc avec ses morceaux le
groupe rendra hommage à l'écrivain boris
vian vendredi 6 novembre le concert aura
lieu à la maison de l'environnement de
magny les hameaux et c'est la fin de ce
set 8 culture merci de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve mardi pour un nouveau
numéro est la bonne soir est sûre télé
[Musique]
non